sind endlich die gravitationswellen
entdeckt worden zumindest kursieren
derzeit gerüchte im netz von us
forschern der nachweis dieser von albert
einstand vorhergesagten wellen gelungen
sein soll
ernst zu nehmende gerüchte die sogar auf
die homepage der science geschafft haben
also los geht's wirklich zum science
fiction
endlich soll es soweit sein die von
albert einstein vorhergesagten
gravitationswellen sollen entdeckt
worden seien
es wäre einer der letzten beweise für
die relativitätstheorie laut einstein
durchlaufen diese wellen jahr raum und
zeit wenn ein kosmisches großereignis
geschieht durch das die gravitation von
riesigen himmelskörpern verändert würde
würden zum beispiel zwei schwarze löcher
kollidieren müssten solche
gravitationswellen durch das weltall
jagen und es krümmel einstein sagte
diese wellen voraus weil die gravitation
ja keine kraft ist sondern die krümmung
der raumzeit das heißt keine kraft zieht
und sie auf die erde sondern eben die
krümmung der raumzeit gravitation drückt
den raum zusammen und wie die
lichtgeschwindigkeit führt auch sie eben
zur längen kontraktion dieses
zusammendrücken das erleben wir als
erdanziehungskraft allerdings ist die
raumzeit extrem steif verglichen mit
einem gummi ist hundertmal steifer stahl
2000 mal und die raumzeit 10 quadrelli
onen mal steifer bisher wurden
gravitationswellen nur indirekt
beobachtet die physiker russells und
josef taylor von der princeton
university beobachten über jahre hinweg
den doppel pulsar psr 19 13 und 16 und
die beiden pulsare näherten sich genauso
an und verloren dabei genauso viel
bewegungsenergie wie es von einstand
vorhergesagt worden war
die gravitationswellen waren indirekt
bewiesen worden und es gab den
nobelpreis für physik für die beiden
1993 immer wieder werden versuche
gestartet gravitationswellen direkt
nachzuweisen
erst letztes jahr wurde der satellit
lisa pathfinder insider
startet die raumsonde hat zwei gold-
platin- würfel an bord und mit diesen
wird eine technik getestet die dann in
einem aus drei satelliten bestehenden
system namens lisa angewendet werden
soll
in dieser parteien sind würfel die rund
35 zentimeter voneinander entfernt sind
und die entfernung wird ständig per
laser kontrolliert der ort für diese
messung wird l1 sein das ist ein punkt
zwischen sonne und erde wo nahezu
absolute schwerelosigkeit herrscht da
dort die gravitation der erde und der
sonne absolut genauso groß ist in leiser
wird die technik dann mit einer
entfernen der satelliten von einer
million kilometer angewendet bei dieser
entfernung ist dann die
wahrscheinlichkeit gravitationswellen zu
entdecken viel höher
aber das ist noch zukunftsmusik jetzt
sollen die wellen im laser in vermieter
gravitation wave observatorio kurz ligo
in den usa tatsächlich schon gefunden
worden seien
das prinzip bei louis leiser und allen
anderen gravitationswellen detektoren
ist immer das gleiche wenn sich
gravitationswellen so verhalten wie
wellen bei einem stein der ins wasser
geworfen wird und so die raumzeit krümmt
dann werden sie auch die bahn von licht
verändern licht hat er eine unveränderte
geschwindigkeit unveränderliche
geschwindigkeit von 299 792 1458 meter
pro sekunde
wenn aber eine gravitationswellen licht
schreibt durchkreuzt muss er sich
verändern daher die raumzeit gekrümmt
wird und damit auch die zeit verändert
wird ein lichtstrahl würde vermeintlich
seine geschwindigkeit verändern
beziehungsweise eine andere distanz
durchlaufen um das zu messen werden in
den gravitationswellen detektoren zwei
lichtstrahlen auf zwei strecken
rechtwinklig zueinander geführt beim
nico sind das 24 kilometer lange röhren
dort wird ein laserstrahl der mit einem
prisma in zwei aufgeteilt wird mehrmals
hin und her geschickt und die
lichtwellen dann so zusammengeführt dass
sie sich gegenseitig auslöschen
kennt ihr vom schall schallwellen können
sich gegenseitig komplett auslöschen
wenn wellentäler und wellenberge genau
übereinander liegen dann löschen sie
sich aus genau so wird das in den
gravitationswellen detektoren mit licht
gemacht passiert jetzt eine
gravitationswellen den täter
doch werden beide laserstrahlen
unterschiedlich beeinflusst da sie
rechtwinklig zueinander verlaufen sie
löschen sich nicht mehr aus und ein
lichtblitz erscheint ja die
gravitationswellen ist gefunden
das logo ist so genau dass die forscher
den gang unterschied der beiden
laserstrahlen perfekt messen können und
auch dann wenn er kleiner ist ein als
des tausendstel des durchmessers eines
protons und das ist ein durchmesser der
beträgt 1,7 mal 10 hoch minus 15 meter
also 000 000 000 000 000 1 siebenmeter
und das ist ziemlich wenig und jetzt
gibt es hinweise darauf dass an diesem
auf satori um veränderung gemessen
wurden die die existenz von
gravitationswellen bestätigen sollen was
man dort gemessen haben will sind die
gravitationswellen die durch die
kollision zweier schwarzer löcher
entstanden sein sollen
die sollen das bis zu 36 fache der masse
unserer sonne gehabt haben offiziell
bestätigt wurde bisher noch gar nichts
nähere informationen stammen von einem
physiker namens clifford burgess der
sich in einer mail auf informationen von
lego internen bezieht zitat spione die
das forschungspapier gesehen haben sagen
dass die gravitationswellen von einem
zusammenstoß zweier schwarzer löcher
gesehen haben dass ein physikprofessor
so etwas verbreitet ist schon
spektakulär so außergewöhnlich dass die
science ist für würdig hält es auf ihrer
homepage zu veröffentlichen aber auch
andere veröffentlichungen zum thema wie
zum beispiel die gravitationswellen in
der hintergrundstrahlung die haben sich
im nachhinein als falsch herausgestellt
wir müssen also abwarten genaueres soll
am 11 februar offiziell bekannt gegeben
werden was vermutet ihr wird die
wissenschaft immer schnelllebiger und so
werden auch immer mehr
falschinformationen verbreitet oder
meint er es könnte was dran sein
schreibt es in die kommentare lasst
bitte auch gerne einen daumen nach oben
da kanal abo kostet übrigens nichts also
abo knopf drücken egal wo er ist und
verbreitet das video über twitter
facebook
undsoweiter nächstes video anschauen
nicht vergessen weitere videos zum thema
findet ihr übrigens in der infobox wir
haben ja schon mehrmals was gemacht zum
thema relativitätstheorie
gravitationswellen und so weiter und so
fort und ansonsten bis dann bleibt kann